nicht nur lob sondern auch geld mit
warnstreiks untermauern die
beschäftigten im öffentlichen dienst
ihre tarifforderung in corona zeiten
infektions ärgernis groß hochzeit nach
einer ausschweifenden privatfeier
erlässt hamm in nordrhein-westfalen
strenge auflagen aufarbeitung von
sexuellem missbrauch die katholischen
bischöfe debattieren in fulda über eine
angemessene entschädigung für die opfer
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster den abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten für den sport ist
norbert lehmann bei mir im studio und
einfach von mir klatschen reicht nicht
wir wollen anständig bezahlt werden so
das motto derer die in corona zeiten
vieles am laufen halten
heute gab es warnstreiks in kindergärten
krankenhäusern und bei der
stadtreinigung die gewerkschaften zeigen
dass sie bereit sind einige bereiche im
öffentlichen dienst lahmzulegen
beim bund und den kommunen sind mehr als
2,3 millionen menschen beschäftigt für
die fordern sie 4,8 prozent mehr lohn
mindestens aber 150 euro zusätzlich pro
monat und eine laufzeit von einem jahr
die arbeitgeber haben bislang kein
angebot gemacht peter böhme über den
ersten streiktag wir sind es wert
erzieherinnen und erzieher heute morgen
auf dem rathausmarkt in gütersloh der
beginn der warnstreiks im öffentlichen
dienst corona distanziert aber nicht
weniger entschlossen
wir sind oft überfordert wir sind oft an
unseren grenzen durch personalmangel wir
sind uns auch gefahren ausgesetzt ich
bin jetzt ja auch nicht mehr die jüngste
wir können auch jederzeit kommen kriegen
streiks auch im norden den kiel 300
mitarbeiter der stadtwerke bei einer
protestkundgebung und im städtischen
krankenhaus wurde schon am frühen morgen
gestreikt pfleger und schwestern ja
durch corona besonders getroffen
körperlich und psychisch mehr geld auch
für die seele ist eigentlich anerkennung
und nicht dass uns gesagt wird wir
können froh sein dass überhaupt arbeit
haben das klatschen allein reichten aber
sind streiks gerechtfertigt angesichts
von hunderttausendfacher kurzarbeit und
entlassungen in vielen anderen branchen
kein arbeitsplatz bei karstadt oder in
automobilzulieferindustrie ist dadurch
gerettet
das den beschäftigten in krankenhäusern
eine aufwertung verweigert wird das eine
hat mit dem anderen nichts zu tun
umgekehrt wenn es keine gute
lohnentwicklung in deutschland gibt dann
ist das schlecht für die nachfrage
die arbeitgeber haben noch kein angebot
vorgelegt sehen aber die forderungen
kritisch absolut leere kassen
die kommunen selbst leiden massiv unter
dem einbruch der gewerbesteuer einnahmen
in zweistelliger milliarden höhe
wir haben das konjunkturpaket zwar das
reicht aber nur für dieses jahr für 20
20 die warnstreiks werden weitergehen
die nächsten verhandlungen sind erst für
ende oktober angesetzt
was braucht es für guten schulunterricht
in corona zeiten
darum ging es gestern bei einem gipfel
im kanzleramt antwort der beteiligten
von bund und ländern schnell die
digitalisierung vorantreiben
deswegen sollen die 800.000 lehrer im
land dienst laptops bekommen dafür
steuert der bund 500 millionen euro bei
schüler erhalten einen daten gutschein
von zehn euro pro monat
außerdem sollen in den schulen
it-administratoren eingestellt werden
bundesministerin carlitscheck nannte die
beschlüsse wegweisend enttäuschend und
zu wenig finden elternvertreter und
gewerkschaften
was deutschland im kampf gegen die
pandemie schon erreicht hat sollte man
nicht in frage
bestellen das fordert bundespräsident
steinmeier bei einem treffen auch mit
gegnern der korona maßnahmen nannte er
diskussion müsse sein aber die eigene
sicht sei nicht die einzige die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist deutschlandweit
stabil geblieben aber es gibt eine
weitere großstadt die den kritischen
wert übersteigt haben am rande des
bevölkerungsreichen ruhrgebiets noten
leinhos lange fühlten sie sich sicher im
westfälischen hamm bis die 180.000
einwohner stadt binnen weniger tage zum
neuen deutschen corona hot spot wurde
der oberbürgermeister konsterniert es
geht aus von einer einzigen großen
hochzeit veranstaltung insbesondere dass
ich sage mal junggesellenabschied feiern
also ein händler fest was sie da
gefeiert haben das ist mit vielen tränen
mit viel tanzen mit viel berühren das
scheint auch einer der hotspots gewesen
zu sein
gefeiert haben mindestens 260
hochzeitsgäste statt maximal 150 wie
erlaubt danach der explosionsartige
anstieg der infektionen die nun
drastischen folgen wieder masken pflicht
für ältere schüler und verschärfte
auflagen für treffen im öffentlichen
raum
der begriff ist zwar etwas schändlich
aber wir werden dann alle in haft
genommen ja für etwas wo wir vielleicht
in teilen gar nichts für können ich
finde schon dass die städte ein bußgeld
verhängen sollte in deutschland haben
für deutschlands hotspot liste derzeit
an
auffällig dabei unter den ersten zehn
befinden sich mit einer ausnahme nur
orte in nordrhein westfalen und bayern
die dortige staatsregierung reagiert
heute für problematische kommunen gilt
künftig auch außerhalb von münchen eine
masken pflicht auf öffentlichen plätzen
und mehr
als zweites thema alkohol alkohol
verstärkt diese bereiche deswegen wird
ein größeres alkoholverbot auf
öffentlichen plätzen möglich gemacht
sowohl für den konsum als auch den
verkaufsstart an die fans von bayern
münchen appelliert söder nicht zum
supercup finale ins corona risikogebiet
budapest zu reisen
mit blick auf das ansteckungsrisiko dort
habe man die geltende quarantäne
verordnung noch einmal verschärft wir
haben gerade einige der chor ohne
hotspots in deutschland gesehen auf der
anderen seite gibt es auch regionen ohne
neuinfektionen in der zdf- heute- app
können sie genau nachschauen wie die
einzelnen kreise derzeit betroffen sind
von einem gefährlichen wendepunkt in der
korona krise spricht der britische
premierminister johnson heute und ändert
damit erneut seinen kurs die masken
pflicht wird ausgeweitet
pubs und bars sollen früher dicht machen
die menschen im home-office bleiben denn
die virus krise in großbritannien
entwickelt sich dramatisch schlecht
zuletzt gab es wieder mehr als 4000 neue
fälle an einem einzigen tag aus london
kerstin herlein gestern abend in londons
vergnügungsviertel soho es sitzt sich
noch schön draußen in der september
wärme doch damit ist bald schluss einmal
bei demnächst das wetter umschlägt und
zweitens weil auf der insel die
infektionszahlen außer kontrolle zu
geraten drohen so ernst ist die lage das
heute morgen nicht nur das kabinett
sondern auch das krisenkomitee cobra
zusammentrat die schließung von pubs und
restaurants ab 22 uhr eine verschärfte
masken pflicht und die neuerliche
empfehlung wenn möglich von zu hause zu
arbeiten sind die maßnahmen die es jetzt
erst einmal richten sollen wir keine
signifikanten fortschritte machen
sollten wir davon ausgehen dass die
anweisungen für sechs monate in kraft
bleiben 61 es ist ein schwieriger spagat
für boris johnson den einen geht das
alles nicht weit genug andere auch in
seiner eigenen partei sind gegen die
beschränkungen
wir können nicht heute leben
und damit morgen leben aufs spiel setzen
ja wir müssen das virus bekämpfen aber
in jeder sollte verstehen dass ein erste
welt gesundheitssystem auch eine erste
weltwirtschaft benötigt die opposition
unterstützt die regelung spart aber auch
nicht mit kritik
angesichts der steigenden
infektionszahlen ist das notwendig
unvermeidlich war es nicht wir haben
gewarnt dass unser corona testsystem bis
zum herbst funktionieren muss doch die
regierung hat so getan als gäbe es kein
problem sollte alles nicht fruchten
droht ein neuerlicher landesweiter
lockdown ein schreckgespenst für die
regierung johnson die alles daran setzen
wird dies zu vermeiden
erst drexhage dann corona ziemlich viel
auf einmal für einen premier diana
zimmermann
wie steht johnson der zeit denn so da ja
die beiden aufgaben des songs sind wären
schon für eine halbwegs
funktionstüchtige regierung sehr große
herausforderung
tatsächlich aber zeigen sowohl corona
als auch der exit die defizite dieser
regierung deutlich auf nichts läuft wie
es sollte der angebliche einfachste deal
in der geschichte so nannten johnson und
seine leute mal den handelsvertrag mit
der eu steht immer noch nicht die haare
hier nutzen
doch die nets moment sogar wo sie was
trinken gehen kosten scheint glaube ich
muss abgeben
erschwerte bedingungen vielen dank so
weit diana wir haben zumindest
verstanden dass die situation für
johnson mehr als schwierig ist jetzt
geben sie ruhe
danke diana corona sei ein china wo es
peking habe infizierten erlaubt die welt
anzustecken worte auf der
un-vollversammlung von us-präsident
trump in dessen land das mittlerweile
mehr als 200.000 corona tote gibt china
weist die vorwürfe zurück und spricht
von stigmatisierung eine schwierige
generaldebatte im zeichen der pandemie
aus new york johannes hano klare
abstandsregeln gegen korona auch bei den
vereinten nationen die führer der welt
bleiben zu hause
der un-generalsekretär aber tritt live
ans pult fordert die welt auf gerade in
diesen außergewöhnlichen zeiten enger
zusammenzuarbeiten
wir müssen zusammenhalten wir haben
gesehen dass herr länder ihren eigenen
weg einschlagen sich der virus überall
verbreitet wir müssen uns von der
wissenschaft leiten lassen und der
realität ins auge sehen
populismus und nationalismus haben
versagt
in einer aufgezeichneten videobotschaft
lobt der us präsident dann das
amerikanische vorgehen in der pandemie
stellt einen neuen us impfstoff in
aussicht und greift china scharf an
wir müssen die nation zur verantwortung
ziehen die diese plage auf die welt
losgelassen hat in den frühen tagen des
virus hat china inlandsreisen gestopft
auslandsflüge aber zugelassen und die
welt damit infiziert die vereinten
nationen müssen china für seine taten
zur verantwortung ziehen weil alle reden
aber vor produziert sind kann der
chinesische staatspräsident nicht selbst
direkt auf die angriffe reagieren
chinas un-botschafter übernimmt das wir
brauchen mehr zusammenarbeit und
vertrauen und nicht die verbreitung
eines politischen virus china weiß die
grundlosen anschuldigungen gegen sich
entschieden zurück weiter könnten die
positionen in den vereinten nationen
kaum auseinander
und viele diplomaten sehen am horizont
schon einen neuen kalten krieg
heraufziehen die katholische kirche ist
unterwegs in schwerem fahrwasser
nicht nur weil die zahl der austritte
weiter steigt 2009 10 ein neuer rekord
fast 273 tausend katholiken haben die
kirche verlassen
ein wichtiges thema bei der
vollversammlung der bischofskonferenz ab
heute in fulda
außerdem wollen die bischöfe klären mit
welchen summen missbrauchs opfer
entschädigt werden
kontrovers diskutiert wird sicher auch
die forderung dass frauen vollen zugang
zur kirchenämtern bekommen sollen stefan
schlösser wie sascha nagel war 14 jahre
alt als sie in einer schule des bistums
limburg von einem lehrer missbraucht
wurde
wie viele andere betroffene fordert auch
sie schnelleres handeln bei der
aufarbeitung
ich glaube es geht in der katholischen
kirche immer noch vorwiegend um
außendarstellung also transparenz und
ehrlichkeit war merke ich nicht so viel
von es gibt bemühungen an einigen
stellen aber es gibt eben es gibt
deutlich stocken da voran als es voran
gehen könnte noch immer ist eine
entschädigung der missbrauchsopfer nicht
geregelt diese soll es jetzt endlich
geben ein einheitliches system das alle
betroffenen berücksichtigt ein
unabhängiges gremium soll über die höhe
der leistungen entscheiden
dieses versprechen sehen alle von uns
als eine große verpflichtung und wir
werden daran arbeiten dass die umsetzung
des neuen erneuerten systems materielle
anerkennungs leistungen hier in fulda
beschlossen wird
die katholische kirche weiter im
krisenmodus kirchenaustritte auf
rekordhöhe zu wenig präsenz in der
korona pandemie gerade in der seelsorge
und der schwierigen reformprozess des
synodalen wegs die kirchenleitung hat
den kontakt zum kirchen volk verloren
das zeigt sich in vielen dingen gerade
auch gegenüber der frauen
und wenn jetzt hier nicht wirklich
wieder ein schritt der bischöfe auch von
rom auf die frauen zu kommt dann sehe
ich wirklich schwarz für die kirche
einen alleingang gegen den willen roms
und damit eine abspaltung von der
weltkirche schließen die beschlüsse aber
aus rund drei monate nach der
krawallnacht in stuttgart heute eine
bilanz
demnach ist die zahl der tatverdächtigen
deutlich gestiegen mittlerweile wurden
93 meist junge männer ermittelt die sich
an den ausschreitungen beteiligt haben
sollen
der großteil war der polizei bereits
bekannt
in der nacht zum 21 juni hatten dutzende
menschen in der innenstadt randaliert
und sich auseinandersetzungen mit den
beamten geliefert
und jetzt zu einem umstrittenen
megaprojekt dem geplanten fehmarnbelt
tunnel
er soll das deutsche puttgarden auf
fehmarn mit dem dänischen rodby hauen
verbinden und rund 18 kilometer am
meeresgrund verlaufen gigantische
einzelteile werden an land gefertigt und
auf die ostsee geschleppt die 217 meter
langen stücke werden hier in einer rinne
versenkt und verbunden
so entstehen vier fahrspuren und eine
zweigleisige eisenbahnstrecke in bis zu
30 metern tiefe 7,1 milliarden euro soll
allein der tunnel kosten schätzen die
dänen die in bauen und betreiben wollen
der widerstand aber ist groß dem
bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig
liegen mehrere klagen gegen das projekt
vor birgit franke die weltretter ein
aktionsbündnis der seit vielen jahren
gegen den bau des fehmarnbelt tunnels
kämpft sie sind heute nach leipzig
gekommen die aktivisten sehen durch den
bau die schweinswale in gefahr und
einige griffe bedroht aber nicht nur das
das ökosystem ostsee darf nicht weiter
belastet werden
gleichzeitig haben sich die
verkehrlichen und die finanziellen
rahmenbedingungen geändert wir reden
heute nur noch über 12.000 autos pro tag
es gibt weitere alternativen es gibt
feste firmenfeste rostig währungen an
anderer stelle auch 34 betriebe haben
geklagt machen wettbewerbsverstöße
geltend das bundesverwaltungsgericht
muss nun ab heute den
planfeststellungsbeschluss umfassend
überprüfen
der geplante unterwassertunnel wäre mit
18 kilometern der weltweit längste für
eisenbahn und auto fahrzeit zehn minuten
anstatt 45 mit der fähre deutschlands
kosten für die anbindung betragen rund
vier milliarden euro
ein wichtiges projekt meint das kieler
verkehrsministerium
das projekt wird ja teil sein eines
transeuropäischen eisenbahnnetzes und es
damit eine ganz entscheidende verbindung
zwischen skandinavien europa und wird
damit neue impulse geben innerhalb
europas für wachstum sowohl in
wirtschaftlicher als auch in
wissenschaftlicher hinsicht
ob der bau des tunnels am ende vom
gericht gekippt wird wohl eher
unwahrscheinlich doch selbst das
ministerium rechnet mit änderungen
heute ist der erste von mindestens sechs
verhandlungstagen das urteil aus leipzig
wird in einigen wochen erwartet
grint wale stranden vor australien das
kommt immer wieder vor
diesmal waren es aber gleich 270 auf
einmal
helfer konnten bislang immerhin 25 tiere
retten
mit boten brachten sie sie von der west
küste tasmaniens zurück ins offene meer
und 90 der übrigen wale sind inzwischen
auf den sandbänken verendet
möglicherweise waren sie auf der suche
nach futter zu nah an die küste geraten
ja und nun zu dir norbert und zu einem
deutschen der gerade sportgeschichte
schreier dem dirk nowitzki dem war das
schon im nordamerikanischen basketball-
gelungen jetzt hat es leon dreiseitel im
eishockey geschafft den 24 jährige
angreifer der edmonton oilers ist als
erster deutscher in der nfl zum
wertvollsten spieler gekrönt worden
diese nummer 29 genießt inzwischen
kultstatus leon dreiseitel in den
letzten jahren zum superstar in der
besten liga der welt aufgestiegen
seine spielweise beeindruckt
[Applaus]
dreiseitel hat sie alle überzeugt
fachwelt mitspieler gegner die alle für
ihn gestimmt haben
ihr habt mich natürlich riesig freut
darüber keine frage gibt sehr viele
menschen denen die nicht dafür danken
muss die die eine riesenrolle spielen
für mich persönlich dass ich so
erfolgreich sein kann
mit 18 sicherten sich die oilers bereits
die rechte an drei seiten von dem man
noch nicht wusste dass er einmal der
beste spieler der nfl werden würde
die eishockey welt verneigt sich vor
einem deutschen pass hat es so noch
nicht gegeben
sechstes spiel sechster sieg die
torbilanz 37 zu null
die deutschen fußball frauen haben ihre
eindrucksvolle erfolgsserie in der em
qualifikation fortgesetzt heute mit
einem 13 0 arbeitssieg gegen die
nationalmannschaft montenegros der
notizzettel von bundestrainerin martina
voss-tecklenburg könnte etwas zu klein
geraten sein das war zu befürchten
nachdem die deutsche mannschaft schon
nach 69 sekunden durch laura freigang in
führung gegangen war
denn dem schnellen 1 0 in podgorica
stand schon ein 10 zu 0 im hinspiel zu
buche zum ende der ersten halbzeit
erhöhte melanie leupolz vom fc chelsea
auf zwei zu null
die auf zehn positionen veränderte junge
deutsche mannschaft dies ist
vergleichsweise ruhig angehen dass 110
länderspiele von kapitänin marozsán
musste übrigens ohne zuschauer über die
bühne gehen am ende stand ein klarer 3
zu-null-erfolg sydney lohmann traf nach
einer knappen stunde für die deutschen
frauen ist die qualifikation für die
europameisterschaft in england 2022 nur
noch formsache
so kann's weitergehen denn hier danken
seit genau 15 uhr 31 ist bei uns herbst
und passend dazu soll es in den nächsten
tagen abkühlen und regnen
ob auch mal die sonne scheint das sagt
ihnen gleich katja hornuf das heute
journal mit claus kleber sehen sie heute
wieder um drei viertel 10 und wir sind
morgen wieder für sie da punkt 19 uhr
jetzt wünschen wir ein noch einen recht
angenehmen abend und sanchez
[Musik]
meine damen und herren so schön
sonnenschein und wärme am astronomischen
herbstbeginn ja es sind viele von ihnen
erwarten jetzt dringend den regen und
jetzt kommt er und zwar gleich von zwei
seiten zum einen ihr von süden mit
diesem tief über dem zentralen
mittelmeer das schaufel regenschauer und
gewitter über die alpen nach
süddeutschland und zum anderen kommen
hier von nordwesten diese regenwolken
immer mehr in unsere richtung heute
nacht lassen die regenschauer und
gewitter im süden erst mal nach
intensivieren sich dann aber bereits in
der zweiten nachthälfte und erreichen
morgen dann auch thüringen und sachsen
und gleichzeitig kommen uns die
regenwolken hier von nordwesten immer
näher an der nordsee werden sie morgen
schon merken dass der südwest wird durch
auffrischt heute nacht ist es in
norddeutschland meist klar und dort
sinken die temperaturen deswegen auf
einstellige werte zwischen 9 und 7 grad
sonst bleibt die nacht milder bei 15 bis
10 grad am morgen erwarten uns dann
häufig noch einmal sommerliche werte mit
23 bis 28 grad nur an der nordsee und
auch in bayern bleibt es bei 18 bis 22
grad etwas kühler
die meiste sonne sehen sie morgen
zwischen der aller und der ostsee am
donnerstag erinnert sich noch nicht zu
viel dann kommt der kräftige regen und
der temperatursturz am samstag gibt es
nur noch sechs bis 16 grad
schönen abend noch